no abundan los precedentes de
conversaciones entre líderes mundiales
que se alarguen hasta casi cuatro horas
esa es la principal noticia que deja la
videoconferencia de hoy entre joe biden
y xi sin tiene una duración que va más
allá de la foto del trámite cosmético y
que parece revelar una intención real
por solventar los problemas o al menos
por atenuar los las transcripciones
ofrecidas por pekín y washington
coinciden en el buen tono ha sido franca
constructiva y fructífera según la
prensa china no ha dejado acuerdos ni
grandes titulares como se esperaba sino
que ha transcurrido por caminos
trillados como el compromiso mutuo de
evitar que la competición acabe
derivando en conflictos ya sean
voluntarios o involuntarios y entre
todos los temas por supuesto taiwán que
tiene una relevancia muy diferente para
eeuu es sólo un peón más en su tablero
geoestratégica una forma más de meterle
el dedo en el ojo a china cada vez que
hay tensiones para pekín en cambio es un
asunto totalmente innegociable y sin fin
ha advertido hoy de que todos los que
jueguen con fuego en el asunto taiwanés
se acabará quemando mientras joe biden
para alegría de pekín
firmado su fidelidad al principio de una
sola china